life is supposed to be a journey and if
you imagine a sailor who went out in a
ship and was just tossed around by the
ocean and then came back although they
endured and there was time lapsing well
he didn't have a journey whereas sailor
who's going and exploring all of these
new lands well that's a journey and
that's what you want your life to be
like it's not enough just to endure and
just to exist you need to be choosing
is it right to say that life is short in
your estimation
it is short I think it is a little bit
too short even even though it's
necessary that it's finite
I don't think it needs to be quite this
finite although
having said that I mean I that's just my
selfishness my ego talking what would
you advise for if you had the choice 250
that would be that would be pretty good
but then if it was 250 would be sitting
here saying I don't know I wish it was
750 you know yeah
but um but it seems to be like the way
that I mean I make this point in the
book The Way the
the memory system and the human mind is
put together
seems to be pretty much well made for
about a hundred
maybe 120 something around that years
because
one of the examples I give is this
classic example from the philosophy of
memory sort of back in the enlightenment
period where there were these debates
between John Locke and uh Thomas Reed
pair of philosophers and they were
talking about
um what the nature of self is and the
continuation of the self
and there was a a memory a memory theory
of the self which is that we're just
sort of this continuation of being able
to remember who we were over our
lifespan
and Thomas Reed pointed out well no this
is we can imagine situations where
when you're sort of in your middle age
maybe 30 years old it's easy to remember
what you were doing when you were five
maybe or a little easier you can
remember scrumping apples when he was a
kid is the example he gives
it's older this um he's opposing it's an
officer he can remember being
um when he's retired he can remember
being an officer but he can no longer
remember scrumping apples he's lost that
bit so there's there's sort of limits
finite limits that have been placed by
biology on what we can fit
coherently in a lifespan and what we can
remember of ourselves to hold ourselves
together yeah because I mean the ship of
Theseus as an example right that if you
replace every board on this ship after a
particular amount of time is it the
still still the same ship and the
difference is that the ship has no idea
that it is a ship or that it can
remember each of the floorboards being
removed I think it's every seven years
pretty much every cell in your body has
been recycled so that there are no cells
that would have been there seven years
before so you go okay well if I am a
ship of Theseus in that regard what does
it mean to say that me now is the same
as me seven years ago or 14 years ago or
21 years ago what does that mean
yeah well this was I mean this memory
idea supposed to take care of that
problem so what so an earlier Theory
would have been where just what we're
made of right you are What You're Made
Of well super Theseus example you've
just presented shows you well no you
can't be because it gets recycled all
the time so you're not what you can't be
identified with What You're Made Of so
there must be something else and one of
the things that you can say about the
ship of Theseus and humans is well maybe
there's at least some continuous thread
through these changes like it doesn't
make sense if you just change all of the
bits of the ship of Theseus all at once
because that's just obviously a new ship
the whole point of that ship of Theseus
example is you're you're doing it
gradually plank at a time so it's not
sort of too significant a change
um so the memory problem was the memory
ID was supposed to take care of that but
then it faces this other problem which
is that there are limits to memory and
what you can hold so it's probably not
memory either that's that's playing this
role or or it is but
you know but then it sort of shortens
necessarily shortens your life
and I make the point that there's um
there's a kind of interesting overlap
here with old theories of
transmigration of the souls and the idea
that we have an immortal soul that
endures
through these various bodies I mean it's
hard to make make sense of that really
because there's not going to be any
record or remembrance of these passages
just like there isn't within a life
so if we were Immortal if we had these
extremely long life spans it would be
just as if we were a bunch of separate
people after a certain time
so it doesn't make any sense to say
that we're Immortal if we have something
like the same memory system and then if
we change our memory systems in such a
way that we can expand then it's not
clear that we're humans anymore and
we're something else and it was this is
what many people want to do right with
this transhumanist business they want to
you know get around
what they consider to be these terrible
limitations of being human-like
mortality and these memory problems and
so on it is interesting to think what is
the single continuous thread and someone
might say well it's it's it's my sense
of I right it's sort of Consciousness or
it's the self-referential element of me
internally my internal texture you go
well
my instinct the texture of my mind is
different now than it was two or three
years ago because I'm always learning
and developing things and if my memories
are in this whatever sort of 50-year
window where by the time that you're 50
years hence from remembering something
especially as a young child that you
basically can't you go okay so as soon
as you can no longer remember something
does that mean that the person who did
the thing is no longer related to you is
that a different person somehow and yeah
I mean I I can I can completely see this
so you mentioned there about the fact
that this is a a conversation and a
topic that's been discussed for a good
while Seneca wrote on the shortness of
Life two thousand years ago over 2000
years ago now yeah yeah what did he get
right and what did he get wrong in your
opinion
yeah well I mean one of the obviously
it's a reference to Seneca the the title
of the book and part of the point of the
book is precisely to reassess what
Seneca did in that book on the shortness
of life which is
an absolutely amazing book it's shorter
than my book as well what do you got I
think the best thing that he I disagree
with him a lot in the in this book as
well I think he gets a lot wrong
especially about the the role of death
and the role of the shortness of life so
he's not so much concerned with
sort of appreciating why it has to be
short it doesn't really mention that he
sort of agreed he's more kind of
um
telling people off or wasting it so he's
saying it's not that it's so it's short
it's like you're just not using it well
enough and if you used it well enough
and wisely and prudently and almost like
a
a kind of
um economic problem where you distribute
the various bits of your life then
you'll find that it's not particularly
um particularly short
so
I sorry I disagree with him on on that
point that you you kind of need you also
need life to be shot in order for all of
the various components that are within
it to make sense and to build a sort of
a good human life
but what he gets right most right I
think
is this business of um
the the provisionality of most people's
lives so he has some fantastic quotes
about
how life is supposed to be a journey and
if you imagine somebody who sort of you
know a sailor who went out in a ship and
was just sort of tossed around by the
ocean
and sort of then came back although they
endured
and there was time lapsing and these
kinds of things well he didn't have a
journey
whereas you know some sailor who's going
and exploring
all of these new lands well that's a
journey and that's what you want your
life to be like right it's not enough
just to endure and just to exist you
need to be sort of choosing and this is
why I think
the having death at the end of it is
vital because it forces you to have to
make choices
if you didn't have that sort of boundary
flashing before you you wouldn't feel
like you had to make choices you relax
and you think I can do that you know
whenever I've got plenty of time for
that so it's in in precisely that
there's
it's precisely the limit of death that
forces you to face the provisionality of
life and not living provisionally and
thinking that you've got all of your
options open and try and thinking it's
good to keep all of your options open as
if it's you know some sort of wise move
like you know this old proverb don't put
all your eggs in one basket and you
don't just don't settle don't choose
don't commit to anything don't be
anything basically is the is the
ultimate
um
uh you know outcome of this kind of
approach so one of my friends gwynda
Bogle taught me about deferred happiness
syndrome the common feeling that your
life has not begun that your present
reality is a mere Prelude to some
idyllic future this Idol is a mirage
that'll fade as you approach revealing
that the Prelude you rushed through was
in fact the one to your death
yeah that's very Seneca
it's almost identical to a quote I've
got in my book where he's talking about
how you're putting things off and you're
saying look when I'm 60 I'll just get
this done when I'm 50 then when I'm 60
then
I can do all of those things and enjoy
life
and um
yeah I also mentioned
um some of
um Carl Jung's theories because he
discusses very similar problems he calls
it the provisional life
and the problem of the provisional life
but he also calls it the problem of the
poor
eternus
which is he Associates this aspect of
living provisionally with a
psychological complex basically and it's
Associated to narcissism
in in modern terminology
um he tried to call it the it was tried
to call it be called the Bacchus concept
initially and it's the idea that you
should live like you should be unlimited
right a pawana attorneys character
thinks they shouldn't be limited by
things like death jobs marriages any
kind of commitment at all because it
pins them down and any limit is not a
Godlike kind of thing to have so they
want to be Eternal children with no
responsibility and if you make a
decision and if you act then you're
going to be held responsible
for that action and you have to be
responsible for the consequences and
that's an adult thing not a childlike
thing so they don't want that
and I mean it's amazing to see how many
people are like this now it is an
absolute epidemic the this sort of
provisionality and sort of enforced in
the politics is that not a natural
byproduct of the fact that there are so
many options open to people you can
travel to more places learn about more
things people don't even have a job for
five years now whereas previously you'd
have had a job for life or perhaps you
wouldn't have even had a job you'd have
been some Indigent laborer under the
feudal Lord of whatever country you are
currently being occupied by yeah I think
that's that's absolutely right it spread
it spreads to a
like a bunch of
um phenomena actually where the meaning
that what looks like a good thing having
loads of options and loads of choice is
not necessarily a good thing so you can
think of you know even things like
digital photography seems like a good
thing but it's absolutely sort of taken
the meaning and value out of the
photograph which used to be a nice thing
you'd take a lot of care in choosing
them and then you put them in the album
and you would actually look at the man
again most people don't look at their
photographs you take a trillion
photographs and they're gone they
disappeared somewhere on your hard drive
never to be seen seen again so it's sort
of you could say the same thing as well
about the um
the in the internet and the Google
Search right you've got all of that
knowledge all of what looks like this
huge possibilities and huge options for
finding things out and it's it's too
much choice and it ruins the sort of
meaning of maybe going into a library of
getting a book and looking at it and it
will have more significance when you
find this fact so it's sort of reducing
the value of many things even though it
allows you know us to talk these
Technologies allow us to talk and do
things like this and they can be very
very good and and um
productive I agree that having so many
options is not necessarily a good thing
because it's then harder to choose well
this is similar Barry Schwartz is the
Paradox of choice right he uses this
great example in his Ted Talk from 10 12
maybe even 15 years ago now
um 50 years ago you go into the jeans
store to buy yourself some jeans and
there's one pair of jeans in many waist
sizes what's your waist size there's
your jeans you're going now and it's
okay well do you want skinny or straight
you want boot cut you want stretch do
you want crop do you want rip do you
want bleached do you want dark do you
want blue do you want like weathered and
all of that choice
from a an economist's point of view
would suggest you can get closer to your
optimal utility function the thing that
I want the most is available to me
therefore I can optimize but what it
doesn't account for is decision
paralysis and regret and the fact that
if you're faced with all of these
different options a lot of the time you
walk out of the store with no genes
because if you're you become culpable
for the sub-optimal decision the more
choices that you have right if you could
have chosen otherwise the fact that you
didn't put the impact of that
potentially bad decision on your
shoulders whereas if you couldn't have
chosen otherwise yeah like no one in an
arranged marriage feels like they chose
the wrong partner they might not be
happy with their partner but they they
don't feel their own same sense of sort
of culpability and regret yeah exactly
the more options that's a very good
point actually the more options there
are the more ways there are of getting
getting it wrong basically it's almost
like an entropy kind of thing kind of
calculation it's a very good point so I
feel like it's a particularly sort of
brutal Paradox that
trying to keep your options open to live
a life with optimal optionality can
result in no life being lived at all
because you're just in this liminal
space throughout it all that's right
that's right I mean and and that's kind
of one of the main again one of the main
points of the book is that I mean I
don't mention this as an example I
possibly would have done had I have
thought of this one of the reasons for
provisionality the reason I give for
provisionality is a little bit just give
us a definition of provisionality just
in case people haven't quite hammered
that home
yeah so provisionality is the idea that
you're sort of as you said earlier
you're waiting for the thing to happen
the real thing to happen so you're
indecisive there's never a decision made
so you you know you might
you know have a a girlfriend for example
and you you're not quite ready to tie
the knot because you think there might
be something better somebody will fit
better or something like this you don't
quite want to buy any of these houses
because you think you another one might
come later it's almost a kind of fear of
missing out on the better option
um so you end up not doing anything at
all and you've sort of got this unlived
life where you're always waiting it's
always provisional what you have now is
never the thing
so it's always pointing elsewhere and
you never settled like that and you're
never real it's almost like a virtual
reality right because you're never sort
of settling into real life
um so that's the idea now what were we
talking about we were talking about wine
yeah why people choose not choose why
people seem to go down this provisional
life is
precisely because I suppose relates to
your example when you make a choice
and you do decide
you there's a knowledge that you are
foregoing these other options right it's
a sacrificial Act
choosing something especially the more
significant the ACT becomes the greater
the sacrifice so
again sort of the girlfriend example if
you decide to commit to one person and
you mean it and you're sacrificing lots
and lots and lots of different
opportunities
if you sort of choose some particular
job I give the example of a musical
instrument like I always wanted to learn
both piano and violin but you're never
going to get really really good if you
if you're you know the more options you
keep open the lesser the less because
you're going to be at one particular
thing so you have to make a choice and
you're sacrificing something that you
would love as well so there's like real
significance in making these choices but
this is where the meaning comes from as
well because sort of with a there's a
sort of meaning in sacrifice because it
gives the thing that you choose more
significance in that way
right if you're having to give something
up
choose the thing that you eventually
choose then it's sort of imbuing this
whole thing with meaning and again it
carves a meaningful life in this way
because if life was unlimited then you
would never have to say no to anything
you would be able to learn the violin
and then learn the piano and then learn
the trombone and then learn the flute
and the harmonica and so on and so forth
exactly right um provisionality would
then be a sort of
the Natural Choice basically you could
live provisionally because you would not
be able to sample all
um options in this possibility space
that you have before you you could just
try anything you can say I'll do that
once I've done this I'll Master this
then I can do that
I'll be sort of married to this person
for a thousand years and then we'll try
them we'll try the next one yeah exactly
okay so I understand that um
somebody who is railing against the
inbuilt shortness of life or even just
the fact that it has an end at all like
I think that seems pretty robust yes it
would be nice if we could do 250 and and
stick about for that long
um but I do think unlimited life would
end up a whole bunch of strange
externalities let's say that somebody's
accepted that
how does this help them live a better
life
they know that it's going to end they've
conceded the fact that they're not going
to be immortal
what is the net what's the next step
after they've accepted that then what is
it to live a meaningful life yeah so
then so it's again going back to this
idea of
um choosing and making sure that the
choices you make are
um the decisions you make are done with
intention
right so this is the fact that you've
got this death
um flashing away at you should be there
to force you to
um avoid living provisionally as we've
just mentioned but also choosing the
particular options you choose with a bit
more care and attention because it
clearly is extremely precious and people
usually start thinking about this at
midlife it's called a midlife
crisis and maybe and I used to hate that
word midlife crisis but if you think of
Crisis as
you know from the Greek word as I
mentioned earlier as decision and having
to choose then it's actually not such a
bad idea because once you get past that
midlife you're precisely aware that your
possibility space is shrinking so you
it's harder to live in this provisional
options open way you can see that you
now have to start making decisions that
are really going to matter and the
closer you get the more options are are
carved away so you can either have the
situation where
you know the world or other people are
carving away those options and choosing
this little final bit of path or you can
figure out which
um path you would like to choose in
those final especially in those final
um bits so one of the other things I
bring in so
I mean it's hard to know
what is the right decision right
um so one of the things I bring in on
this point is Young's notion of
individuation
and the idea of individuation is
basically to try and make it so that
they did the actions
you're carrying out
are truly actions that match
um I don't know how to put this your
kind of true self your true authentic
self
because otherwise although it it looks
like you're making decisions it can be a
whole bunch of external things such as
traumas or from influences from outside
from sort of media you know a lot of
young people seem to be because they're
so heavily buried in social media they
think that they're choosing things and
being very unique in how they're carving
themselves
and they think that it's them that are
you know carving themselves it's quite
clearly coming from a bunch of external
influences that are molding them from
outside so if you don't want to be I
mean the analogy young gives is sort of
being bobbed around like a cork in an
ocean right it's just being pushed
around by everything else rather than
making its own way in that ocean
so individuation is
the idea of figuring out what those
complexes are that might be affecting
you and influencing your decisions what
projections you might be putting out
there onto the world so that you're not
seeing it right because it's being
colored by all of these projections and
things that are being put into you so
that any decisive action is is truly
your decisive action an authentic action
so this is quite a modern this is a
common thing now in a lot of literature
it's presented in different ways but
this is sort of Young's great invention
this idea of individuation and making
everything unconscious as close to
Consciousness as possible so there's
nothing
you know and then you don't get caught
you don't sort of find yourself
wondering why you did a particular thing
I spent 20 years climbing up a ladder to
find out that it was against the wrong
wall
for example yeah basically that kind of
thing why did I get drunk again why did
I do this again why you know why did I
just spend this many hours doing
something I really didn't want to do
because you know that there is something
inside you that Rebels whenever you do
something stupid or you spend too long
doing something you know you know you
shouldn't do there's a thing that knows
you shouldn't do it so it's trying to
make the all of the unconscious drivers
um transparent basically so you can deal
with them it seems to me I've been using
the term uh consciously designed life or
intentional living and both of those
seem to make a a nice amount of sense
here like the number one lesson that
I've taken away from 600 episodes on
this podcast is that you do not to live
need to live your life by default you
can live it by Design and you get to
inject yourself in
ahead of the way that your past traumas
and social norms and societal
expectations and what your family wants
you to do and the path of least
resistance and the fact that the couch
is comfortable on a Thursday night all
of those things every single one of
those there are predispositions that may
push you toward one particular path or
another but it is within your power to
be able to redirect that it is within
your power to be able to choose how you
respond even if it's just internally in
a situation where you're completely
restricted right this was the man search
for meaning this was Victor Frankel's
like major Insight from that as well so
given the fact that
we're both saying here intentional life
design individuation don't just be a
[ __ ] bogging bobbing around in the
middle of the ocean
that means that you need to take time
and care and attention when it comes to
making your decisions
but there's also this other price that
you need to pay if you take too much
time and Care over your decisions
because you end up in the liminal space
Purgatory again and now you're dead and
you haven't started living your life is
this the fundamental tension between the
two
that's absolutely it so it's um I sort
of explicitly refer to it as a bouncing
act it's a bouncing act between these
two
styles
of living so there's the poor eternus
which I mentioned which is this
unlimited style which you know it's not
all bad that this unlimited style is
sometimes good it can push you into
doing things you wouldn't you know
otherwise do it's a bit more sort of
risk taking which can sometimes be good
means you don't stagnate
on the other side there's the over
analytical cynics so um Jung calls it
the senix which you know relates to
Seneca it's like the old man kind of
archetype
and and it can become
um a psychological complex as well so
either side if taken too far can lead to
problems so the Cenex problem is okay uh
you are pushed into an action exactly as
you say because you're analyzing
everything you want to make sure you
make exactly the right decision you
don't screw anything up
um you focused on too much on the future
on making it right maybe too much on the
past and thinking about what happened in
the past so you're not living in that
way either but you're not living if
you're overly poor focused either
because you're not genuinely making
decisions and forging a path you're just
doing everything you're just trying
everything out with no intention so it's
this really and it is a very difficult
thing uh thing to do and you'll probably
end up swinging one way at some stages
in your life and then swinging the other
way
and part of the problem is part of the
problem of forming a life is to have all
the various bits arranged at the right
times so there's a time for
this poor energy which kind of energizes
the life there's a time for being cynics
and sometimes you might require a little
bit of the poor energy later in life
right you might get revived in some way
by a little bit of that and not as I say
stagnate towards the end of your life
so exactly it is exactly this um this
difficult balancing yeah there's an
article that I must reference on
a monthly basis what do you want to want
by Kyle Ash and Rhoda it came out in
2017 uh and wow would you look at that
his uh website it would seem has been
taken over by a Canadian pharmacy which
is trying to sell erectile dysfunction
medication so I must message him and get
him to sort that out anyway in it he's
got two quotes both of which make me
think about this one I think it's an
Aristotle quote
um if a man knows not where he sails no
wind is favorable and another one which
may also be Aristotle it might have been
someone else from the the stoicism era
talks about this sort of listless man
who steps out of his doorway on the
morning and if you to ask him where is
he going what are you doing with your
day and he'll say I'm not really too
sure I'll go maybe I'll see some friends
maybe I'll talk a little maybe I'll see
if something comes up and yeah he it it
seems that there is a
an
immediate comfort in this because your
regret minimization in the moment is
maximized right by making no decision
there can be no regret immediately you
feel no felt sense there's no
um
uh
Choice cost needed at all right you pay
no choice no cost at all for doing this
however the longer that you do that for
the more you're going to look back on
your life and realize that you just
treadmilled your way through everything
at the mercy of the Winds of culture and
Trauma and norms and parents yeah I mean
it's exactly at the mercy I mean so the
way it's quite existentialists all of
this and the way Sartre puts it is that
you can either behave as a as a subject
as an active subject or you can behave
as an object
and objects are things that generally
don't have as Aristotle mentioned
um purpose they're not purposive systems
they're not teleological they're not
they're not aiming anywhere they're just
being pushed around by natural laws and
whatever forces
um desire to take them the same as this
listless men right he's not acting as a
purpose of purposive system which
presumably is what it's
what being human is all about is that
we're purpose of systems we're supposed
to have
um aims so he's behaving as an object
and we all do it we all go through these
little phases where we're not quite
aware and then every now and again we'll
pop back into ourselves and think wow I
wasn't kind of there for a bit you do it
naturally when you're driving I mean
it's amazing how automatic
we can be and just be pushed around by
the circumstances and it's a really hard
thing
I mean we do it in meditation obviously
the whole point of meditation is to try
and be aware constantly
I mean the trick is to try and just
bring that into everyday life always so
that you're always meditating in the
sense of always being aware of what is
trying to push you what is trying to
move you and making sure that it's you
uh that are making the decisions
and usually that requires having a name
right it's hard to make a decision if
you don't have some intention and aim
Beyond it that it's taking you towards
I had a conversation with Ryan holiday
about his new book discipline his
Destiny and I came to the opinion that
without any goals there can be no
discipline because when you talk about
discipline it is in service of a thing
right to the person for whom their goal
is to be in the top note Point not not
one percent of people that watch hours
of tick tock per week them sitting on
the couch and watching tons of tick tock
is in service that is their discipline
it's in service of their goals yeah for
the David Goggins of the world who wants
to run 20 miles a day getting up at five
in the morning and shouting expletives
in the mirror that is also part of his
discipline
yeah
yeah you've just reminded me of a yeah
another point I was intending to make
earlier which is
um
sort of this Vivid it's not important to
have this Vivid
um image this Vivid picture of the
future that you want and that I mean so
I mentioned in the book some experiments
that have been done um
where those that can form a very very
big picture of a future self right a
future version of them
um have generally do do better overall
so it's the vividity of that future
um aim this sort of goal the person you
want to be in in the future that drives
it as well and if you don't and the less
Vivid it is the less you're going to be
driven by it what were some of the sort
of um things that people were thinking
about was it the life they had was it
the type of person they are was it their
friends the type of person they wanted
to be so if you so you know if you want
to get sort of really fit and you want
um to improve your body it's it helps
enormously to have the most Vivid
version of that future image that you
can possibly have and there were sort of
experiments done where people would be
shown because often what happens is
you end up thinking most people end up
thinking of their future versions and we
even call them future selves
as if they're a different entity and I
actually mentioned that I think this is
a mistake in the book it's just you in
the future it's not a future self as if
it's a stranger it's you in the future
and it's still going to be you present
over there
so I'm sort of very against this idea of
thinking of future studs and the effort
there was a bunch of fmri studies done
which showed that some people think of
their future selves or use the term for
now
um in exactly the same way as they think
of strangers
so the same bits of the brain are
lighting up when they're thinking of
that thing over there in the future
as when they think of a complete
stranger and that's a problem and the
more you can make it so that that thing
in the future is associated with how you
think of yourself and not a stranger the
better you're going to be at driving
some disciplined sort of um schedule to
take you somewhere so it's not only sort
of
you know
um
um plausible there's kind of good
experimental results that have been done
to back this up that this this sort of
image and this this future goal this aim
this technological uh Target is really
crucial
what was the danger of bulletproofing
yourself
bulletproofing um bulletproofing is
it's sort of
I mean I should just say so this
there's a whole range you probably know
that maybe you know them you're wearing
a fitness top there's a whole range of
um bulletproofing Bulletproof
sort of Fitness Products keto and these
kind of things
um it was developed by this guy Dave
aspray who noticed that people were
people in Tibet are somewhere were sort
of had really good energy and their
bodies were sort of very good from
drinking this ghee coffee mixed with
fats and stuff like that so he was one
of the first people who realized that
you know this sort of having lots of
fats was a very good thing and he
developed this stuff called Bulletproof
Coffee where you mix it with
gay and whatnot and that's that's fine I
actually quite like these kind of things
but
he started saying things in his books
like you should sort of remove
everything that makes you weaker and old
was one of the quotes
he gave and this I mean that's kind of
um on the way to narcissism is the point
of this it's like very poor
eternus archetypal comment to make right
don't be old don't be weak you've got
you know just eradicate all of that and
the end point of that is
um
sort of this thing that the
psychoanalyst uh Gene Arendale caused
the Fortress of I well what what ends up
happening is that what you're presenting
to the world is just this sort of shiny
beast that's there to prevent any kind
of harm or risk or damage but it's not
real right nothing's like that nobody's
really really like that you can make
yourself fit and it's good obviously I
sort of do this you can sort of try and
be healthy and these kind of things but
the limiting case that he's trying to
push towards sounds like absolute
narcissism so there's a whole chapter on
what happens when you push this desire
to be utterly unlimited and
uninvulnerable to the Limit and I think
you end up with this strange
um projected
um creature that is not really human in
any way and some people like that again
some people are just obsessed with this
idea of getting Beyond human but I don't
think we're very good humans yet anyway
we haven't tried being properly human
yet and probably you know as you say
consciously creating our circumstances
what was that quote that you had about
um about how people use social media was
it something like people would rather
appear happy than be happy something
like that
yeah I mean what they're doing is I mean
they're presenting and
it's the image again they're presenting
a projection they're they're more
concerned about how they appear than how
they are basically and this is you know
it goes back to the the options that you
mentioned earlier right they go around
there's like a trillion pairs of genes
that they can try and they're sort of
carving
through appearance thinking that that's
going to Define who they are and there's
not really a lot going on sort of
underneath that we used to teach people
to work on
you know sort of this inner aspect of
themselves we don't seem to do that
anymore it seems to be very external
because what's getting presented the
only thing you can really present on
social media is an external snapshot so
you need to make that external snapshot
as good and bright and as sort of
impressive as can possibly be and that's
the focus that seems to be the focus of
things I mean imagine what Seneca would
think of these things he would I just
can't imagine if you saw
Facebook and social media well I don't
have social media I can't I can't bear
it well I think it it makes a lot of
sense I have a bunch of friends who also
can't use it but for better or worse
it's here and yeah we are defined by by
our opinions and appearances now and the
thing is that we've now in the modern
world being able to detach opinion from
grounding in something to back that
opinion up greater than has ever been so
for instance I can proselytize online
about how altruistic or great my
relationship with my mother is Right
meanwhile going home and then treating
her like an absolute piece of [ __ ] I can
do that and the gap between what you can
present online and the reality of what's
occurring has never been so wide
yeah exactly it's the author again it
goes to the um the individuation and the
authenticity thing again I mean what you
really want and what's going to make you
feel
the best and most in control is if how
you are presenting yourself to the world
is how you actually feel because then
there's no lie nobody's lying about
anything then but it's a kind of
deception right and the only person
you're really deceiving is obviously
yourself because then you constantly
feel like [ __ ] because you realize
you're constantly acting right
everything's
everything's this put this big
performance and then you go back and
you've you know you're somebody
completely different so there's nothing
wrong with choosing a you know this
particular
um these particular clothes and there's
nothing wrong with covering yourselves
with tattoos if that's what matches
but it never matches it's generally
something because they feel [ __ ] so they
do these things
rather than just becoming yeah becoming
who they are there's an interesting
situation occurring online that relates
with this in the uh content creation
world are you familiar with audience
capture do you know what that is no I'm
okay so
um audience capture occurs when a
particular content creator online finds
content that resonates With Their
audience and then begins to further
Define what they make by what they think
the audience will want so they start to
throw more and more red meat toward
Their audience and ends up becoming
basically a caricature of what Their
audience thinks they are and there's
this example that my friend Gwenda the
guy who I gave you that quote about
earlier on does this amazing article on
sub stack that you'd love called on the
Perils of audience capture there's this
guy called nicardo avocado who used to
be a vegan violin playing YouTuber and
he was like this sort of thin
um kind of like nerdy sort of dainty guy
and then he started doing eating
compilations on YouTube where he would
eat food like huge amounts of food and
he was getting a lot of attention for
doing this and the plays were going up
and people were giving him what he
wanted which was public uh Focus
and it has got to the stage now where he
is gone from being this thin spindly
violin playing vegan to this sort of
awful fat slovenly screaming guy with a
CPAC mask on
350 pounds permanently in and out of the
doctor because he has been he says uh
the person was subsumed by the Persona
that's how he describes it yeah that's
absolutely
um it's tragic and it's kind of our
fault really as as a society to be
incentivizing
incentivizing that kind of thing and
again it's the social media obviously
that also incentivizes this kind of
thing by getting the hit but it's an old
um phenomenon of course I mean you think
of somebody like Marilyn Monroe who had
this Persona she was apparently
completely different she was quite well
read and quite erudite
off screen but she had to constantly be
this other person for her audience right
the bubbly blonde books you know bought
some kind of lady and it inevitably
leads to Suicide like I would worry
about this guy who's doing this if it's
so
heavily Divergent from what he clearly
is from his initial point of origin he's
in trouble and he's probably going to be
needing some actual psychological help
every time that he disappears from the
internet for a little while which he
does for periods sometimes he's in
hospitals sometimes he's just doing
other things or whatever there is a
non-minor contingent of people that send
out an alarm call saying we need to
check we need to make sure that he
hasn't decided to top himself because
he's no it's millions of people I don't
know how many subscribers it's lots and
lots and lots of people who have been
observing the slow motion
self-immolation of this guy on the
internet and I do understand what you
mean you know we shouldn't be supporting
this Behavior by watching it but it's
the same compelling reason that people
rub a neck as they go past a car crash
right like it's it's so limbically
inbuilt in us and he has reverse
engineered a type of content which Taps
into something and then has leaned into
it more so the dynamic goes both ways
everybody talks about the echo chambers
that you get into online and these
algorithms are so manipulative because
they are able to find the exact thing
that you want to watch and they can
deliver it to you no one ever talks
about what happens reverse to the
Creator the Creator gets shaped by the
algorithm and the audience in the same
way that the audience gets shaped by the
algorithm and the Creator yeah yeah I
mean it's also interesting from the
point of view of sort of highlighting in
a really Stark version what we all do a
little bit of
like we all present a version that we
would like to be right we might like you
know when you're young you're really
concerned about your appearance we all
were I was
um when you're an academic for example
just starting you want to present
yourself as this kind of very I don't
know over-the-top intellectual you might
even arrange like when I was younger
there's a confession
um and I was um I would have somebody in
my office I would arrange books of a
particular kind really impressive books
sort of on my office shelves as if I've
been reading them to look like wow that
guy's reading these Quantum field Theory
books that's amazing like how pathetic
is that but it's a similar kind of thing
it's just exactly the same kind of thing
I'm presenting
something for other people this is not
for me it's not doing anything for me
it's not who I am but I want them to
appreciate me but they're not
appreciating me they're appreciating
that thing there that's exactly what's
missing percent I did a tedx talk a
couple of years ago and this was a big
chunk of what I spoke about where I said
that
um
if you are not careful
any praise that you receive won't ever
existentially feel like it connects with
you because if you're only playing a
role people aren't uploading you they're
applauding the Persona that you are and
this is why I think you get
um some deaths in the acting world
because the Robin Williams of the world
or the heath ledgers you know when
someone applauds the performance they're
not we're not in love with Russell Crowe
we're in love with gladiator we're not
in love with Chris Hemsworth we're in
love with Thor right and the Detachment
from the two for a big time I was this
well-known club promoter and did all of
this stuff and it was fantastic and
people knew my name but it didn't
fulfill me in the same way as doing the
podcasters and I think that that because
despite the fact that I adored the work
and loved the lifestyle and thought I
was super proud of what I'd achieved
but in a crowd of a thousand people I
was still able to feel a little bit
alone because I had to put on a front
and because I was putting on a front and
performing in a way any time that
somebody came over and gave me a
compliment it it didn't really land
because I was like oh you club promoter
Chris just received a compliment how
fantastic for him
yeah yeah exactly I mean that's probably
one good way of gauging
um how authentic you are is how well you
can take a compliment from somebody
whether they can just go okay yeah good
like thanks
because it goes either of one you know
it can go a number of ways however you
feel like [ __ ] because it's not really
complementing you as you say it's
complementing this character that you've
built this is what I meant by the shiny
Beast of I by the way earlier it's the
the character that you've built this
invulnerable character that's being you
know applauded and these kind of things
so
um so it can go that way or you can be
again like the cork in the ocean
um pushed around by it and it's exactly
this sort of being sort of built up if
you get a compliment
you sort of start to thrive
on seeking those compliments and that's
probably and that's exactly what
happened to this guy who started eating
right there was sort of some sort of
attention and compliment and you
realized you could get it this way and
you want more and it you get pushed by
it so again it's sort of this um being
an object or being uh an agent an actor
somebody who's creating the script as
you go if you're getting pushed around
like this you are not in control if you
if you get a criticism and you go oh my
God and you're down for ages you're not
in control you're being absolutely moved
around like a cork in an ocean other
people's heads are a wretched place for
your self-worth to live there was a
quote that I found last week from
Stephen pressfield in turning pro the
amateur is a narcissist he views the
world hierarchically he continuously
rates himself in relation to others
becoming self-inflated if his fortunes
rise and desperately anxious if his star
should fall the amateur sees himself as
a hero not only of his own movie but of
the movies of others he insists in his
mind if nowhere else that others share
this View
that's very very good I like that a lot
and yeah I have something a little bit
similar where the the narcissist and the
poor I think they sort of have this idea
that they're constantly being judged
right they're the sort of other people's
movies and I mentioned they feel like
they're being sort of
you know people are following them
around like a big marching band always
watching their every move waiting for
these these things to happen but like
again I had some of these these kind of
um
issues myself like some of this book was
self therapy or sort of recognizing a
bunch of these slightly narcissistic
issues that I had especially this sort
of comparing with others like I would
always have to try and
better everybody like be the best do the
hardest thing like with piano I would
learn the hardest pieces with like my
physics stuff it would have to be the
very hardest areas of physics that I did
otherwise it wasn't good enough and it's
the bulletproofing thing to be the
absolute best at everything and if and
it would sort of
it and it's exhausting because obviously
you can't do everything
you can't be good at everything but I
would try to be good at everything so
this was a sort of a way of trying to
eradicate all of these these issues that
I was Finding in myself to
yeah to not be exhausted all the time
and not have this deceit constantly
going on what a difficult cause that you
have learned to use to remind yourself
of the stuff that we've gone through
here because you know it's
philosophically very compelling sounds
great I need to remember the shortness
of life I need to think about my
decisions beforehand but not for so long
that I die before I make them and I need
to all of this wrapped together is great
but
when it comes to applying this what is
there something that you rely on a
mantra or or an Insight that reminds you
of the shortness of life and reminds you
of the importance of decisions and
reminds you that you need to be in
control of your own destiny
I don't know I think the main thing
the main thing I do has to do with
um
I don't know in terms of work I'm always
trying to only be doing the thing that I
would do
if I wasn't getting paid for it if I was
left just to be able to choose whatever
I was doing at any moment I want to be
doing that now and that's kind of what I
I am doing right at any particular day
I'm generally doing what I would be
doing if I want being paid for it
that's a really tricky I mean you have
to engineer it but it took a long time
to get to this stage and it and it was
by using things like this vividness of
the future
that you want right this sort of
picturing almost like a movie that the
future that you want them and then it's
essentially a series of steps like there
is
even though it differs the kind of steps
that you would need to do differs from
your starting point obviously some
people are poor some people don't quite
have the uh sort of natural
um skills in whatever in music or
whatever it is that they want to do so
they're gonna it's gonna take longer or
shorter some things might not really be
possible so they're going to have to
make compromises and change that future
but I generally always
have a positive future image in mind and
then it makes all of the awfulness that
you have to go through okay because it
because it is awful engineering a good
life
is absolutely brutal and and painful
right you have to look at how many
podcasts you're doing a week I you're
sort of reading a bunch of stuff but it
doesn't feel awful because you've got
this sort of aim at you want to find
things out right you want to find truths
so my ultimate aim is a similar thing I
suppose right I want to know the truth
of this world and why we're here the
mysteries of this world of people
whether this
more to it going on and that sort of
pulls me through all of the arduous work
and learning of new things that that I
do as soon as you posit an ideal you
begin to compare yourself to that ideal
and inherent in that is Disappointment
when you fall short so how do you deal
with the inbuilt
um
fear of failure
um well you're you're always going to
fail I mean it's always going to be an
Ideal Image it's never supposed to I
mean look it's never going to be a
um it's probably never going to be
realized and you probably never don't
want that ideal to be realized because
then you're sort of you've sort of lost
a component of meaning that was leading
you towards it right it's the path
towards that image that's sort of
providing the meaning the decisions and
the things you have to do to get that if
you make it there well you probably
didn't have a high enough
um goal in the first place or then you
need to set a more impressive goal I
don't think you ever in that situation
how do you avoid yourself being
permanently dissatisfied though if
you're always setting the goal one step
further than you can run to does that
not permanently leave you in this sort
of sense of inferiority
curiosity I don't hmm
[Music]
I don't know it's certainly a problem
because you because you're always
striving you're certainly always going
to be striving but I don't have to me
that's part of being alive is this
striving to a goal you should I mean
maybe that's the time you know if you've
if you've achieved your absolute
ultimate goal that you've been striving
towards for your life then you can I
would suppose die kind of pretty pretty
happily
but until then like it's the striving
that's the that's the interesting thing
and meeting the obstacles you had this
guy you had Ryan holiday he's the guy
that did that obstacle book right
obstacles the way is that the guy yeah
yeah that's that's exactly that's kind
of very similar he's chosen a different
form of limitation I was focusing on
death but it sort of applies to
limitations and obstacles in general I
mean we feel good when we're battling
and in fact I give an example at the end
of the book
um there's a biologist John Calhoun who
tried who did these experiments on
Utopias
um biological experiments using mice
and he tried to raise a set of mice in
utopian conditions where every need was
catered For there was no obstacle there
were no problems they had all their food
and everything and they didn't they
didn't fare so well as the mice that had
lots of obstacles and were having to
fight for their food and battle for it
and had scarcity now and again and it
seems like the Utopia and some of them
died some of the mice actually died
because
everything was was given so it seems
like this idea of having a utopian con
conditions and not having any obstacles
or constraints or limits just leads to
uh absolutely dystopian kind of
nightmare of a life where you can't
stand it you can't live in that even
mice can't handle it was it Marcus
Aurelius who said the whole universe is
change in life itself is but what we
deem it I think it was and it's that
life itself is but what we deem it bit
that seems interesting to me because
the story around the challenges that you
face and the difficulties and the
setbacks and so on and so forth is for
the most part your experience of it like
that's not for me to say that if you're
to snap a leg and you just tell yourself
that oh this is fun I get to experience
or having a snapped leg is like that
it's going to be that much better but
certainly with
all of the Myriad of just daily issues
the sitting in traffic the extra time
with the kids in the car on the way to
school it's like is this is this making
me late for work or is it extending the
time that I get with my children like
yeah yeah you know the story that you
tell yourself and your reframing of it
it is for the most part what's going on
it very heavily colors almost entirely
your experience and especially given the
fact that in retrospect you're not
really going to remember the thing that
happened but you'll remember your
experience which was colored by your
interpretation
yeah I mean that's the like the classic
um stoic mindset right you can you can
choose how any particular event is all
internal like your entire world is
internal basically so you can choose how
you're going to deal with it if you get
you can choose to be offended you can
choose if you're stuck in traffic
whether to be pissed off by it or think
this is an opportunity for me to think
about that problem I wanted to think
about like I broke my ankle recently and
I was because it kind of took me off my
I was like very speedily doing things
and I was not really thinking so I could
have been pissed off by breaking my
ankle but I thought it was you know an
opportunity to slow down and deal with a
whole bunch of other things that I had
to deal with so there's a you can I mean
I'm sure there are really bad things
where you it's very hard to have this
kind of stoical approach if you've got
some
you know really awful
kind of injury but um with most ordinary
day-to-day inconveniences they don't
really need to be inconveniences but
it's obviously hard to do and it's dis
it's part of the discipline Again part
of the Habit you need to get into a
habit I think I do I do now have the
traffic habit I must say I developed
this because I I'm always stuck in
traffic these days so you you can either
go mad or you can use it
it's interesting to think about
um I'm playing around with the idea of
the end justifying the things that you
went through which means that you're
miserable on route to it and then if
you've posited a sufficiently high goal
then sometimes you're never going to
achieve it
um this is why I think it's so important
in advance to make sure that the things
that you're doing are enjoyable in the
moment right like if you're doing
something which each individual
iteration of it's fine like it'll be
great when I have a big Studio that I
can enjoy going into work and I never
have to answer an email again and I've
got a big team and all of this stuff
that'll be great but the path on route
to doing that each one of these podcasts
that I do is also enjoyable like this is
I'm not paying some unbelievably huge
price and even when there is discomfort
sitting down and reading a book that's
that's hard or whatever trying to learn
something in a really condensed period
of time or doing a podcast when I'm
under slap because I've just flown back
from New York or whatever right
even that is like well all right it's
it's challenging but it's challenging
towards something which I genuinely care
about and it's challenging in an
enjoyable way so yeah there are people
that are in positions that are so
limited that they can't just pick and
choose their entire life like that like
I I understand that but I feel like
there are far more degrees of freedom
that people can have in order to be able
to do that and there's this quote from
uh an episode I did with Peterson two
years ago now and uh it was so good I
think it relates to the other side of
this equation which is the
um over optionality optimization
contemplate the price you pay for in
action you're already in a little hell
you know perfectly well it's going to
get worse the thing about inaction is
that you're blind to it do not make the
assumption that inaction has no price
um that's a very nice quote uh another
quote I like which I give quite I think
I give it yeah I get it in the book
which was by Terence McKenna
uh Terence McKenna had taken lots of
mushrooms apparently and it was a
mushroom that said it to him and he said
look you need to you need to have a plan
because if you don't have a plan you'll
be part of somebody else's plan
which is again it's sort of this this
same idea it's either you are going to
move yourself or you're going to be
moved by somebody else or the world I
mean what do you want which one do you
want you don't prioritize your life
somebody else will that's the
fundamental realization yeah yeah and
again you can do this in in many ways it
doesn't have to be huge massive
ridiculous you know world-changing goals
all the time it can be many things but
it just has to be you that's choosing
them it's absolutely crucial
Dean Rickles ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the book and
your work if you've got a website you
don't have social media where else where
can peanut find you do you exist online
are you a digital ghost
I'm a digital ghost I think I have a
university webpage I think somebody did
a Wikipedia page but there's lots of
books on Amazon
um as well with information there all
right I should maybe yeah I appreciate
you thank you mate see ya what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]